moment diese explosion
mein name ist mein team und ich bin
chemikerin ich forsche an farbigen
lösungen also an knalligen farben in
erlenmaier kolben außerdem erforsche ich
die wechselwirkungen zwischen etting und
glasscheiben und natürlich forsche ich
an explosionen also an dingen die
explodieren stets von selbst ich bin
heute hier weil ich mich öffentlich
gegen die einseitige und sehr
klischeehafte darstellung von
wissenschaftlern aussprechen möchte wenn
man sich bilder von wissenschaftlern
anschaut dann repräsentieren die selten
die ganze realität also meistens sind
das alte männer mit grauen haaren
diese darstellungen sind ja auch höchst
unattraktiv für junge frauen und mädchen
in unserer heutigen gesellschaft und da
fragen sich alle
ich habe wo bleiben denn die frauen in
den naturwissenschaften wenn man immer
nur alte männer mit grauen haar sieht
dann verfestigen sich solche klischees
wie das wissenschaftlerinnen kein make
up tragen also ich trage sehr viel
make-up das sieht man eventuell manchmal
nicht je nach explosion aber das eine
schließt das andere nicht aus forschung
wissenschaft als ganzes aber auch als
beruf sollte etwas sein womit sich viele
menschen identifizieren können und wie
als wissenschaftler sollten menschen
seien personen seien zu denen junge
menschen auf gucken wie sollten
vorbilder seien
aber solange wir immer so lächerlich
klischee auf dargestellt werden wird das
nicht passieren ich möchte die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
da draußen dazu aufrufen dass ihr
nachzutun in die öffentlichkeit zu gehen
sich zu zeigen damit wir dieses alte
lächerliche wissenschaftler klischee
endlich hinter uns lassen können
[Musik]